dude that does nothing for you guys
yeah
that's just nothing for nobody in here
he is that a good-looking creature sure
creature yeah he's a good-looking
creature is he a good-looking man no i
don't know i think he is you know what
you are yeah you're a hater nah bro yeah
yeah yeah sometimes [ __ ] just sucks
you're not necessarily a hey look at
this [ __ ]
that's you chris dude that's what you
want
when i think about how it's me i like it
a little more
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
rolling rolling on the river it's more
like rolling on the river wow you know
who's probably real bad at singing you
yeah
do you think i am not i'm not even
trying to be a dick you have many times
really and it seems like you're all no
no no no i'm not
fast
will
so
right when dio sings he turns really
asian you never heard him saying i i
already know really asian you have many
talents i do i'm leading with that what
do i do singing i do christmas carols as
my number one thing
i do it's silent night or not bad
oh what do i like rocking around the
christmas tree and i'm rocking around
because it's fine
you're a bad singer too though yeah yeah
so it's not me no i do opera right no
i'll do opera right now dude just
because you will i'll do opera right now
no just because you eat pasta and you
[ __ ] turn the tv up loud doesn't mean
you do you want to do opera do opera but
i'm just saying the phantom of the opera
is here
[Laughter]
is here
[Music]
dude i've done [ __ ] personal singing
lessons i've done regrets
what does that even mean comes from the
guy who says so many extra words dude
you put personal in front of you because
you're calling me a singer
me and a dude named [ __ ] well i don't
want to see his name was cause i'm gonna
say he had a lazy eye but he would kill
it at the piano dude and not sing and i
would just be like suddenly
life is new meaning to me
you know what i mean i do that kind of
[ __ ] glory up above
and things i've never even done enough i
think if my dad invested in my singing
like yours did yeah yeah well i'm
meatloaf but yeah i'm trying to think of
things i like to sing i like to sing uh
oh if there's like if i'm at a um at
church mm-hmm i like to sing at church
you know how many times uh
how many do you go to church you seem
like you'd go to church just on easter
you're there no
i go to church more than easter i would
say i go to church once a month really
yeah
wow that's almost as much as our patreon
is it oh
yeah yeah
you see how i do it so smooth i've been
so smart
yeah king of this thing in the wing
we don't need no
education you do that at church
no i do a lot of uh
foreign songs i do what else do i do
chen is it a black church country oh
billy idol
you do uh what's a guy what a wicked
thing to do
you got some anger inside of you yeah i
do and it comes out of my [ __ ] tunes
it's not what i say
and i'll
hit you guys over the face with a
[ __ ] c sharp
if i need that
croon and angry okay obviously church
and the therapy is not helping daddy
that's trying to church therapy and
things underneath the electricity
all right well whatever so what do we
got dude i'll be this is what the guy in
this chair says so what do we got here
chin
nick nick so what do we got nick and if
you put their names together
[Music]
if you do chin and nick just half it
and this is all of his name in the end
yeah and it shouldn't be and i don't say
it anymore take out the n in the first
end
i'll think it but i'm not saying it
that's my new thing
what is this huh that's chin and nick in
one person
but we got
a new segment we talked about two weeks
ago uh we're having people oh it's bobby
lee after rehab dude
[Laughter]
people are going to tell us a little bit
about themselves and then we're going to
guess who's famous
before you even play it uh delia fan yep
he's got the
he's the chain but he has the carhartt
shirt oh he's a john chris it's a mix
it's a mix let's we learned a little
about him first yeah okay let's learn a
little about him first what's up king in
the sting my name's nick i'm coming out
of sunny southwest florida i'm 33 years
old beautiful wife and a four-month-old
baby
on my off time i like to go to the beach
hang out
at the pool do the woods anything
outdoors
i'm a supervisor at the home depot yeah
well he's too happy to be a theo fan
yeah i i i maybe it's my ego but i think
it's me and i think it's me okay
florida is delia florida's dalia i don't
know though if if it was texas if it's
jacksonville i just murdered florida but
if it's jacksonville but you're not we
all have fans everywhere all right yeah
take it easy yeah you're great but it
just murdered okay okay i know don't say
it in the premise of the french way
bleeding i don't know if there's blood
coming out of it very good very good
very good i really like talking like
that dude just murdered this that's good
that's good that's good
so just murder florida okay good good
good good you keep saying that no but i
i just readily impersonated let's ask
i would say
for some reason i'm thinking theo i
don't know why yeah well what do you
think i'm saying but i am thinking this
guy his manager at a home
depot he also included the woods
something he likes to do so we don't he
likes to be in the woods that ain't your
fault it's not me but you can listen to
my [ __ ] in the woods you can listen to
my [ __ ] in the woods and there are a lot
of things that are theo-ish like he
works at the home depot that seems like
a fan that [ __ ] theo would have
styles not field his thoughts
not theo his style's more meaning it's a
little bit me and you but also the
carhartt shirt kind of throws people off
because i would think that that would be
a king in the sting thing which is not
me until recently classes me chain is
man y'all closeted y'all keeping talking
about this dude i'm just gonna guess bro
okay i'm just gonna guess nick i'm gonna
say that the guy is a brennan shop fan
fair enough he's too happy to be here i
think brendan made a good point he's not
crying i think it's me no brendan's also
drinking whiskey oh good
sucks to be the most famous here yeah it
does it does yeah but that's good so now
the tough part is this one's gonna be
different now no not necessarily what if
they were all brendan forever
and i'm using your random generators to
pick them up to not try to like trick
you guys really yeah i don't want to so
it could be three breaths so it could be
okay fair enough are we doing more yeah
oh all right theo fan
oh a hundred percent but let's hear her
but let's hear her
hi guys
my name is emma i'm from portland oregon
but i went to college in athens georgia
25 i'm currently single i'm a cpa and i
work in public accounting at deloitte
for fun i love to work out i'm actually
outside of the gym right now
i love to do things outside i have a
paddle board i love hiking swimming all
that stuff i love trying new food eating
good food i think that's probably half
the reason i work out
um
i would say i come from an upper middle
class family and i'm an only child
and i'm a fan of thanks you got some arm
calves on the baby you saw that you know
what [ __ ] she cries every wednesday you
know what theo fan i'm gonna go this is
a dalia fan this is this theo nick do
you know chin do you know i don't know
no no it's nick knows because he knows
i was gonna guess you for sure but now
i'm starting leaning towards chris i was
gonna guess you in the beginning and i i
did start to lean towards me a little
bit more i know for a fact it's not me
because my crowd is all cocked so as
soon as i see a drug man
same nose right yep yeah well same
eyebrows i'm sorry i'm sorry for her
because my nose i think both y'all look
decent yeah yeah and she's pretty yeah
she's a pretty girl yeah so here's the
deal uh
i think we're realizing that my i need
to get my ego in check because uh so far
i was like both of these people have to
be fans of
me yeah
i hate that i thought that this is the
theo fan though i'm not shocked you
thought that and i thought it was a theo
but then i i did what chin did i was
like could be me but
what do you think now you're just
guessing me to not be guessing you
though
50 50. it's one of you two yeah you got
it
i think that this is a crystallia fan i
think it's a theo fan but she's from
portland dude i feel like people from
portland [ __ ] absolutely hate me
really i don't know portland is my best
selling city actually
dude my northeast for me i'm sorry
northwest for me too yeah mine is the
whole world
and chicago phoenix chicago yeah
you know why phoenix right
you're live
you know why phoenix right
oh yeah they're pretty oh you need an
history
yeah no because it's very very very
republican
oh yeah daddy
that's where i thrive at so no um okay
theo this lady i think is a nice lady
i'll say you but but deal she also went
to georgia yeah i say theo athens
that's kind of your area is it
yeah it's your area dude hey man shout
out to um
you got that
nope i don't know who i say for you all
right hit it nick
crystal ah
[Applause]
okay that makes me feel better though
makes me feel better though hey guess
what big bad
nice damn good
you're good with two guns like that yeah
[ __ ] that
yeah
knock knock who's there [ __ ] people oh
dude
wow you guys i don't you don't know
nothing i don't like this
i don't like how you can do me too theo
needed this win man i don't like how you
can do me as well
you don't lie i don't like it because it
makes me think
[Laughter]
oh man ufc 272 is here this saturday we
have a live fight companion calabasas
fight companion josh barnett matt matrio
and myself 7 p.m only on think boy watch
it with this listen with us have a good
little time but also make some money man
you're talking about colby cumden jorge
mazvidal ufc 272 you got to do a
draftking sports book the official
sports betting partner of the ufc and
boy do they have a knockout offer for
the new customers bet just one dollar on
the main event and get 100 in free bets
no matter what could be a first round
knockout decision a draw no contest no
matter what the outcome you get paid son
if sportsbook isn't available in your
state yet you can still feel the thrill
of ufc 272 with draftkings free play
pools everybody can enter for free free
pool with ten thousand dollars in prizes
answer a handful of questions like how
long will the fight last who will walk
out the winner and follow along to track
your results download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
kats throw down just one dollar on the
ufc 272 main event colby comington jorge
mazvidal who you got make some money
watch a cowboys fight campaign and you
get one hundred dollars in free bets no
matter the outcome that's code kats this
saturday at draftkings sportsbook the
official sports band partner the ufc
must be 21 or older minimum age and
location requirements vary by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
sportsbook for a full list of
requirements and state-specific
responsible gaming resources void where
prohibited minimum 5 deposit gambling
problem call 100 gambler in tennessee
call or text the tennessee red line
1-800-889-9789 in connecticut call
888-789-7777
hope ny or text hope ny to 467-369
download draftkings app right now promo
code is k-a-t-s ufc 272 let's ride
man listen i'm the only person in my
house don't speak spanish it's
exhausting my kids talk trash about me
my girl talks trash not anymore
i'm not gonna let him in on the secret
but your boy's been learning spanish
with babble that's right babel the
language learning app that sold over 10
million subscriptions not only is it
learning a new language fun and engaging
but listen you can use it while you
check off traveling more from your list
the whole babel process is super easy
it's fun it's fast babel teaches
bite-sized language lessons for real
world use not that boring stuff you
learn in high school we're talking about
real stuff here man babbles 15 minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go i do it in my
car while i'm driving to work so i can
come home and see what all the smack my
family's talking about me other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but not babel babble lessons were
created by over 100 language experts
their teaching method has been proven to
be effective with bow we can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
like your boy here french italian german
plus babble speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
accent all that stuff man there's so
many ways to learn with babble and
additional lessons you can access
podcast games videos stories even live
classes plus you have nothing loose
20-day money-back guarantee start your
new language learning journey today with
babel and right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you get
an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
think about it 15 minutes a day you're
gonna be fluent in six months man just
go to babel.com
use the promo code k-a-t-s that's babel
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code is k-a-t-s babble language for life
what up values
to noah from nashville i mean 25. we're
done wrap this up all right i've got a
wife and a one-year-old daughter got a
house wrap it up
i'm a warehouse manager for a furniture
store so not that ballin
i love furniture video games and
skateboard play guitar
and work out
a bunch of really childish [ __ ] but uh
i have a gay father so that's uh
this is theo all day long bro
your
your father could be gay your father is
not john your father has something about
him as well
he's old he's a theo fan all day yeah
no no questions it's too easy
theo
he knows
you want to go three for three you gotta
guess theo you know that
okay that's the
crystalline oh my god
wow
and you don't know anything wow you
didn't even pick yeah
[Laughter]
please have a podcast where you do that
just you just announce that well this
guy looks just like me so probably my
fan house
this guy looks like
this guy
if i wasn't on carnival what did you say
the way he said it this dude is my fan
i'm ready for a fan
he's the friend jumping what up king of
the sting it's your boy jaker no
strawberry i'm trying to figure out
which one to use my rider today
so uh a little bit about myself i'm 28.
jaker first of all not even a real name
that's mine
that's a slurp that's a racist of
whatever his real name is we have
something yeah look at these jakes over
here
and then there's one
speaker what the [ __ ]
i'm so he looks too much like me man
he looks like my middle brother waltham
massachusetts
um love playing golf love going down to
red sox games to see how many fenway
franks i can suck down uh
i like going on reddit and starting
rumors about bobby lee i prefer women's
deodorant over men's deodorant because
i'm a dove boy for life
uh
and i also love getting way too personal
with uber drivers oh theo though this
guy's making me totally honest guys
i don't know how to spell the word
squirrel without googling it scares me
that's we're both stupid hopefully that
helps you figure it out i'll give you
guys a second to talk it over
i
who could it be dang she or me theo you
think
no brendan
no he looks like me it's a bro he goes a
[ __ ] game but he also said his dad
passed away didn't he no he never said
anything about being sad he's a gay dad
i think i think it's uh theo
there's no gay there and what happened
he worked where does he work at he
didn't tell us dude wow this jake likes
to hang out
line him up that's a theo fan
but the answer to the question is mr
double cheeked up on a wednesday
afternoon theo vaughn yeah oh
wow
i'm jealous though why not me you know
what i mean i'm pissed all these people
specified they loved all three of you
really is really the podcast they
started with
uh
the shapes need to form something when
they match like power rangers voltron or
voltron well power rangers is the i mean
that's but they turn a big monster yeah
i know but oh but but voltron turned it
into a cool road you guys are just doing
something else no no we're talking about
your idea dude the the logo turns no uh
one uh yeah oh this is what's his name
yeah it's an eagle with a crown and [ __ ]
and lightning bolts yeah or just the
lightning bolt that's the body
what's up king this thing this is caleb
live in chattanooga tennessee 30 years
old is this [ __ ] ugly man
[Laughter]
that makes me a fan of
when he's talking about kids theo
doesn't have a kid that's you chris or
me it's you and i'll tell you why it's
you oh yeah tell him because he is no
but tell him i'll tell him i'm gonna
tell him he's dying no and there's one
specific
reason why he's your fan and i realized
that him no only these people
uh these people can be also our fans
uh but the
but
no i'm sorry what is it
okay well here's what it is yeah you
tell us jesus it's that he his voice
doesn't go up and down when he talks
it's very monotone and that's your fault
and i don't know i feel disrespectful i
feel like it's an attack but it's not an
attack there's a lot of those kinds of
monotone speakers out there and your
brain scans kind of like that dude
honestly
but he's just talking like this and it's
not he's not doing like this or like if
you're starting like this or this is
this it might be my fan could be a theo
fan there's no one yeah but there is no
this is just straight off it's like
hit it nick
[ __ ] on you it wasn't your fan and i
dissed you
he's awesome dude you would hang with
this [ __ ] push him in
no i don't push you man dude he has his
phone in his hand
hey guys adam here from sunny ibiza
spain i'm a 33 year old male oh single
but seeing a nice italian girl so i'm
not going to say completely single yes
that's good my family living
in the sunny south coast of brighton
i've been here for years i work in the
port making cocktails on nice party
boats and
yeah for fun i also like to party in the
nightclubs and stuff out here and keep
myself in shape and train i've been a
very funny you guys for years and uh
keep doing what you're doing have a good
day peace out and as you can guess i'm
you know why he's saying this some
worldwide oh man that sucks dude he got
international no but if beethouse always
sounds like a place no one can pronounce
i think that's why probably he's your
fan
and because he he hits that [ __ ] you
know he's got that lip coma every now
and then when he hits a hard word
and i think that this guy though is a
good energy high energy guy yeah and
that's why it's a brennan fan
because brennan is just like it's got to
be brandon i mean look at the the
beginning image is just hilarious i'm
almost the only one worldwide here so i
don't know
brendan shaw
god bless and he said he's in england
right now yes and god bless england too
and god bless scotland my mama's english
and now you're leaving
now you're leaving countries out you
said you were well hold on why why are
you saying you're international dude i'm
the only one here who's international
but why are you saying it i want to can
you explain it please yeah okay cause i
start has anybody else here toward
international okay well he has yeah when
china in the past he you did chosen
north korea right
china
he did china china okay did you do china
yeah what was that like that's insane
china was china is
how did they not [ __ ] make it out
there alive wow i'm gonna go ahead and
say that yeah it's awesome right
but it's also the people are not it just
they seem like just like uh slaves like
slaves
they're robots the kids that's about it
two tickets for theovan yeah yeah
yeah it's a lot of bots yeah i love
living here everything is fun talking to
somebody and suddenly they'll all just
the whole family will shut down
the kid the breastfeed will just they're
at the drive-through you're like what
the [ __ ] taking so long you realize
the family's in the car just shut down
yeah yeah yeah it's a lot of people
eating also they eat whatever though so
how yeah i know if you spit someone will
slide and catch it amazingly strafe over
just [ __ ]
thank you
yeah dude 100
thank you for the spit it's the alvin
[ __ ] yeah dude with your [ __ ]
that bottom lip thank you the oven
bro a hundred percent dude straight wow
did you just straight [ __ ] you just
straightforward that's a crystalline fit
game's over yeah okay but they're both
crystalline
i don't know man this is this is rip my
drip they want uh to hear what you guys
think about their outfits we got a
couple people i'm in some [ __ ] like
cheech and bong over here these boys
aren't some [ __ ] techs to see if i've
ever seen them this is eve
on the left and ball man on the right
there are two rappers from dalton
georgia
fan do we have a video no no of course
there's a video somewhere though uh
the guy on the left outfit
i i there is something i cannot stand
and i will continue to not stand it sure
and it's bucket hats i've never been i
cannot wear a bucket hat they're so bad
looking i think i'll tell you what goes
on with these two so they're a dynamic
duo rap group the guy on the right gets
all the chicks got on the left cries
every saturday night because he's not
getting any of the hot chicks yeah it's
a theovon fan yeah but let me tell you
something right now though
the guy on the left is such the dark
horse when it comes to getting the
hottest chick trust me the guy on the
right gets the bad chicks that's what
ugly guys say though
hello dude there's something crazy about
me though i'm not ugly huh
no no we put it together last week that
you got the different pieces right yeah
the x factor right right in a unique
form the guy on the left has got that i
think he's got that freaking pants
randall on him he's got that wiener
brother
he's got that wiener that sleeps back
behind his butt it's so long it's
[ __ ] in his butt yeah like how you
lose your cell phone in two [ __ ]
couch cushions that's how his dick is in
his butt this is them yeah well this is
the guy on the left this is uh back on
pills
back on pills baby
[Music]
cause after i'll be here without you so
either
[Music]
uh
okay i'm happy to see these guys and i
hope they i hope they continue that guy
okay i'll just for me the guy on the
left's outfit that's horrible yeah but
the guy on the right is fine i get it's
a style it's just not my style you know
he's got a shirt on that you would wear
brendan and uh the shoes are okay the
jeans are fine um i like his shape with
the beard and [ __ ] the hair i don't
normally like guys with [ __ ] longer
beard hair than hair hair it looks like
he's got that and i call that upside
down head she's shut
it's too long down here uh yeah but uh
they both are not really
you know but i'm talent bro that was
telling me right now he got on the left
i would be lying for him if i was
looking for drugs the guy on the left
yes skateboard of drugs that's my guess
he reminds me my friend patrick from
high school that
would get us all extremely high and then
stop at the gases but you guys go in and
get something like in the middle of
nowhere and he would leave i like that
guy
i like that guy and he would leave and
i'm talking he would leave town wow and
he'd come back three months later wow
and it was like he went hard on a real
also bread and shot fan
oh yeah oh so wait this is the outfit
rate her outfit yeah rip the drip rip
the drip she says she gives us a little
influence oh okay let's do the info damn
that it's like she looks like it looks
like she yeah like her only her thigh
got mad like the hulk and then that's it
just the one yeah just like you would
like you wouldn't like my left leg when
it's angry
[Laughter]
just starts kicking that thigh peeking
through the blinds baby
nova jeans
hey cats crew
my name is brittany i'm 33 years old and
i'm from illinois
i'm sending you this video
on the photo that i sent
is my outfit from new year's eve
i
recently got divorced
and
um
it was time to get my [ __ ] together
i started doing low carb and exercising
five days a week and i've lost 80 pounds
wow
celebrate i went to st louis for new
year's got wild and i just want to see
what you all think about what i wore
i thought it was time to get a little
body
thanks for all you guys do thanks for
getting me through the day love y'all
gang buzz buzz god you know i love that
you can feel her happiness about all
this you know what i mean and you
deserve to be proud because that's so
[ __ ] awesome that she and she's a
sexy girl yeah and she's killing it and
she knows she is and this is her right
here her like coming out look what i did
you know what i mean lost some weight
and she went and she [ __ ] went out
she got a bell some belly chains i like
one leg is thriving and the one leg is
popping no that one like that she was a
hit and st louis a thick white girl
yeah that one then she got that
louisville slugger on that one leg baby
that thing's bro this is her walking
down the street saint louis you know
what this is blocking [ __ ] yeah black
[ __ ] nice
nice singles dude yep st louis forget it
yep i think uh i like the way she's
dressed i think it's i think she looks
hot
i'm in she killed it she killed it and
this was a perfect submission to send in
a picture and a little video about the
outfit yeah this is perfect i will say
uh pose in a different place
that's just the price that's bad in the
back is clearly a high-speed chase going
on that's a helicopter behind you this
is a bridge between two buildings i
think downtown
[Music]
like a hotel and a parking structure
just like look at the [ __ ] thing on
the bottom like the the old telephone
jack or whatever the [ __ ] that is like
oh yeah yeah what are you doing it's
like the ethernet cable so if we could
critique anything it's that oh no get
out of here dude oh
that's a recruit
that's mark maron that's cool that's
mark mirren that's mark mary's probably
hating on me and rogan that's cool that
is damn is that that is eric griffin
yeah oh my god he lost he looks like he
lost weight in this race
honestly that's randy quaid in christmas
vacation
[Laughter]
that was when he went to detroit god
look at this is he that scared a covet
but he rolls up in here but he check you
know you check some boxes for her
covet tests in four days that i'm
cleared for travel you have to maybe you
have to do that i don't know maybe his
wife making him do that you don't then
why did he do that travel all the time
she's trying to get him to do that if
you want to hit that slick socket
dude slick socket call it a fried
butterfly
ew dude
what that's what it looks like
good call it
upside down
what do you guys call it
call it just call
a lot of serial killers from his area
yeah yeah yeah he was just waiting he's
all
god
[Music]
i got one gash by the way look how [ __ ]
eric is taking it with the two hands
dude do you need to such a grand
young girl where's my kids younger dude
if my son were here he'd help me yeah
he says all the time
all right all right do co-test in four
days clear to travel see you soon what
is he [ __ ] talking
that's weird that you don't need to do
that and he's bragging about it
everyone's like what are you talking
about
theo fan
game's over this is just a horrible
outfit
i like how he's him i i do appreciate
that he's
uh
no
he looks like miley cyrus if she's trans
it's the whole thing is that
he is just uh
that all that [ __ ] doesn't give you a
personality you know what i mean like
311 meets seven of them this is 10 11.
that's what this guy looks like i think
a little bit and he has the tummy tat
and the pharmacist i wish he was showing
what that is yeah where's your next hack
gonna be chris be honest sacramento
you're going to get one up there no um
uh i'm probably going to do it on my
chest
the full chest i want to do the full
chest do it again what daddy uh yeah bro
are you chet hanks
i could be i would love to be i'll tell
you what dude i'm going to get a
triceratops
you know why your son's face he's trying
hard son loves it dude he doesn't
he's he'd be his favorite
so tops yeah dude and it's so cute
that's like brendan
well that's why i got this one that's
more like i'm sorry the first one my son
can't say zombie so he wakes up and says
chomby so that's why i got here
but i thought i thought maybe i would
get one either here or
i don't know where it was sorry put on
your [ __ ] face at this point
that's why and just get like horns
and one horn would it be cool if you
shave parts
there and then you could grow the hair
out back over it and every now and then
surprise him with it or
shave it have him do the triceratops and
only let the top part of the triceratops
head grow hair so it's like the
triceratops has hair so it's a trihera
tops
that's what i'm saying
good evening guys
oh wow that's good no like you're proper
i like it yeah i like that profession
guys good evening guys welcome to a very
special time for announcements
[Music]
king the sting and the wing we're
hitting patreon son yup tell em chris
march 10th march 10th is the episode
that drops that is exclusive for patreon
what are we doing two on patreon and two
free on youtube that's right yeah so
that's the deal from now on yeah um it's
called the takeover yep so every other
week will be patreon every other week
will be
on youtube um and why are we doing it
guys
[ __ ] a little bit more uh we're gonna be
on patreon there's going to be no ads on
there yeah because the ads they
sometimes sometimes the truth is the ads
kind of
they they they
they just i don't know they get upset if
you don't do certain stuff some of it
you just i don't want to deal with yeah
we get it fighting back you're getting
crystallia theovon my stealth and myself
king the sting and the wing buzz buzz
gang gang shore
this guy couldn't look more [ __ ]
unexcited i mean look at the first frame
dude he's highest [ __ ] he's either
unexcited pluto or he's yiddish dude
downloading information right now that's
what he's doing
he's uh oh he's on heroin he's plugged
some advice okay yeah
brandon what's up mr eric griffin by the
way eric man i love you on this show and
i love you on workaholics max wanna
throw that out there well he's not here
my question is i got laid off a couple
months ago from my job and ever since
then my girlfriend's been paying for
damn near everything um when we go out
she pays for the motels the food uh
turtles um pretty much my question is am
i elle boyfriend for letting her do that
for me or a w boy from finding a girl
that'll do that type of stuff for me hey
man
mental health is real i love you bro
you're both mental health in israel
yeah yeah and that's yiddish
yeah
i don't think it's a w or an l if your
girl is paying for you while you're on
the [ __ ] you know yeah dumps it's
just a relationship like she got your
back while you're in the dumps i assume
you're gonna get your [ __ ] together and
quit doing drugs and get off the couch
and get your mental health right you get
a job yeah you don't just keep sucking
out our cash tit you feel me that was
crash but yeah i like this guy i like
this guy he definitely seemed like he
might be getting into a uh
might be a little too comfortable
well that's true i think he didn't blink
also during the video which i think he
could be a night watchman
so he could do a job like that oh um
and
i think if your girl's out there working
baby this is what the weight this is
what women wanted
they wanted to be out there like all
that [ __ ] they want it and so you got to
be supportive and let them have that
thing be at home stand by the door when
they get there yeah dinner [ __ ] get
ready like what they do when you get
home when you get home be there complain
to her yeah be there be like hey is
there more stuff you can do i don't
appreciate it enough you know what i
mean have a lit cigarette for for
watching stupid shows yeah yeah yeah
on the couch talking about how your day
was so hard even though it wasn't really
that hard tell your stories about your
friends exactly he doesn't know exactly
yeah right yeah park down the street
while the maid's at home and do
something on your phone yeah a hundred
percent dude
call back call back from the last
episode if you didn't listen to the last
episode go back to the episodes ago
you'll listen to the part one of that
diss
alrighty
we know who's fan that is
relationship question for you guys
been with my current girl for about six
months i wanted to spend every day with
her is he the micro machines man
i didn't hear a word that [ __ ]
just said
he does have a small mouth oh yeah
his mouth is upside down we all know
that you can tell his mouth is upside
down imagine his mouth was the other way
that's a top lip on his body he's got a
top lip
under that is um unbelievable
he got the baby spitter dude you know
what he's got that salvador dali yeah a
little bit
for about six months i wanted to spend
every day with her every second moment
hour all that good overwhelming husband
awesome i love her
question is
is this maybe a little too much too soon
spending this much time with her um
should we both have
some space between each other some gaps
here and there um or is it okay to kind
of be moving this fast and be seeing her
as much as i see her
um after only six months of dating so
he hands to her and she's just tied up
somewhere
and he didn't blink i want to take back
the blank from the previous one i want
to give it to him yeah okay his eyes are
far apart you know what i was just gonna
say yes
beat me but you know what you know why
his eyes are far apart because he's
because the two sides of his mustache
are far apart as well so basically uh
everything's scared of his nose so let's
so so so what is the question i didn't
hear he's overwhelming he wants to spend
every second every minute with his girl
they've it's only been six months yeah
you're smothering her dude wait your guy
likes it too though she likes it too at
the moment and you can't actually say
it's only been six months so long that's
kind of a long time you know when you
know so maybe you guys just love each
other and stop being so don't think
about it too much i'm smothered don't
think over things
don't overthink stuff too much do you
know what i mean
i do
that's mother dude
you start with smother dude then you end
up with covered then you end up with
missing dude that's how you go
you're going to be three steps
you say stuff like you've said it before
and i get jealous dude you're good man
you're good
you leave me alone you remind me of the
sister from roseanne and you're making
wait you have said that before am i
right
have i really you've called me that
before that's amazing awesome dude okay
i use this shirt i do i do i do look
like her like yes yes
oh wow there you go that's you dude
that's cool
that's me he looks like lester hold a
little i'm lester holt more like lou
holds
holt
i'm lou holtz dude lou holt i saw him
there you go that's his right mouth
that's how it should be oh my gosh
amazing he's way way better way better
he's handsome he just went from a four
to a five sorry dude i'd say four to six
really
there you are again i used to have that
shirt
straight up yeah if i shaved that's me
this hair is the same
your forehead's exactly [ __ ] [ __ ]
sakes dude whatever i'm a hot chick
she's hot that's a kiss shirt because i
she was attractive i remember right now
i was never into her no not my thing
she's cool i like the way she talked
mm-hmm there was you know what something
about her facts yeah
oh bro this is uh is this uh what's his
name
j baldwin
this dude is sexy
some eyebrows what up king in the sting
fam what's up brendan what's up theo
shout out to the rest of the gang
um i got a king interesting
what is it guys that wear rings
we know how brendan feels guys tell me i
got a couple friends that really like to
hate on the rings
um i don't really get why
personally i it gives me
a confident boost um
and
it even gives me an edge right i'm gonna
go shake a hand
if i'm gonna go grab a drink okay you're
thinking about it a little bit you know
you over that's the right amount to
think about i really wanna go all out
i'll even do a second ring oh no
i like how we magically you know what
that goes back to your thing he's a
magician you guys tell me unless you
know magic
yeah unless you know magic can't win
i'd like to see him go full and do
cirque du soleil or to do a heavy neck
brace oh i'm into that like the african
style where they do the rings on the
neck just really
it's too much
no you say this in a year you'll have 70
rings i really like that you say that i
really like that you say that because i
could totally see that happening but
it's just
you're gonna have so many [ __ ] rings
yeah it's gonna be like that kid's thing
where they put the thing on the
different things oh yeah like that i'm
just gonna get breasts knuckles [ __ ] it
[Laughter]
and just wear it fashionably not even to
beat people up there are some guys who
can pull it off
there's certain guys that can rock the
rings and [ __ ] who is it is it a
tough guy that can wear a ring
like a jared leto vibe bro can you stop
sucking jared leto's dick you're not
even sucking his dick it's like you're
sucking his nipples yeah and he's not
even a woman dude you're [ __ ] you
gotta stop talking about [ __ ] jared
leto he is a [ __ ] cuck dude
yeah
dude he wore an orange a bright
yeah that's it just show that
dude that does nothing for you guys
yeah
that just nothing for nobody in here i
think he's a good-looking creature sure
creature yeah he's a good-looking
creature is he a good-looking man no i
don't know i think he is you know what
you are yeah you're a hater nah bro yeah
yeah sometimes [ __ ] just sucks
you're not necessarily a hey look at
this [ __ ]
that's you chris dude that's what you
wanted
when i think about how it's me i like it
a little more
[Laughter]
that's you at the laugh
that jacket's pretty fresh but the hat's
got to go the jacket's fresh bro he's an
avon like i say it's
like it's all like this you know it's i
hate it i hate it i hate it i hate it i
know same thing right there he's an
except bro he's a nerd he's a uh he's
one of those beings from the future
amazing look what they did right there
is what i'm telling you same guy
he's unprecedented he's like a dolphin
here's the thing about do it all here's
the thing 30 seconds to mars dallas
byers
won an oscar
the joker
no that's where i draw the line dallas
buyers yes 30 seconds tomorrow sure
maybe it's good [ __ ] i have no idea
about that and he has a bunker in his
house dude yes he's a bunker from the
war
okay and he's 50. okay so here's the
deal here's the updated here's the
amendment okay because sometimes we
speak too soon right yeah he's fine okay
but you still need to stop talking about
him as much as you do that's what is the
problem right
brendan the liaison to him
is brendan
yeah and i saw jared leto once in a car
he was pulling into a parking lot
and he goes like this
and it was unbelievable the way he shot
he's pierced me with his with his with
his eyes yeah and i'll give you that but
guess how many times i've thought about
it uh three or four times it's like the
ocean of a million women landing right
in your [ __ ] eyeballs when he looks
at you god you're a [ __ ] poet you're
like zoe neil hurston
thanks dude
there she is
and here is jared leto again
[Laughter]
if he wants to be yeah or this is a doll
yeah
she's she's in a horror movie whatever
it is oh yeah you know what i mean and
she says something like of course and
you're like that's it
you know what i mean that's it
we're all dead margaret i'm from san
antonio texas and i have
a can or sing it for you
living at home with the parents as i'm
currently doing
stuff to help pay off hell yeah students
do it loans
i still have about like sixty thousand
insights left so i'm trying to like save
every penny so i'm really trying to stay
for a long time with that money
towards becoming debt free
so yeah i don't know i do feel like a
little bit of a loser though sometimes
when i like want to go out or have
people over and i kind of can't yeah um
so yeah can you understand let me know
beautiful
first of all mark ryden i think is her
father
obviously i don't know who it is he does
art he's art guy okay he's an artist and
if you pull up something he doesn't want
to see
we'll know that
also her bets kind of led to the parents
give her the master's bedroom i think
she was trying to say i'm at my parents
house and showing her parents bed
because she didn't show her parents i
think that's her best she looks then why
did you say i live at my parents house
and show the background of her bedroom
it could be her bedroom that doesn't
live at the parents house
well what i'm saying feels bad for her
though she can't go out you know what
dude she's got this i don't feel bad for
her because she doesn't need that or
she's gonna be at her parents for like
six years okay and that would be
unfortunate but what about that seventh
year that's going to be an amazing year
yeah
and you got to think positively and
here's the deal
because life rips yeah even at your
parents it does life rips even at your
parents and for your parents because
your parents get to have you there and
they love you i'd love if my kids stay
with me 100
so here's the deal dude yeah we get it
it's a situation that you're in and it
can suck but you're not a loser because
you got to do what you got to [ __ ] do
and you know what we generally love you
for that because you're a person and we
generally love people we don't love you
personally because we don't know you and
that takes nothing away from the fact
that we love you gentlemen we don't want
to be crazy what are you saying no she
knew that she knows i fall down you i
followed that i'll tell you that i
support her this lady seems like a good
lady mm-hmm and i believe that if you
have to stay at home stay at home man
mm-hmm you know your parents made you
and they there was no contract when they
made you that you have to leave at a
certain age that you're gonna leave a
certain age so you [ __ ] stay in there
you [ __ ] stand right by their face
while they brush their [ __ ] teeth
yeah i'm sure they've bought it because
they started it yep they did start it
and honestly die there stay there until
you die yes pass away there yep and
let's bring up a mark ryden painting
real quick if we can actually
just be invasion hey this guy punched in
the nose huh yeah no he's trying to
breathe better
oh you guys are all about the nose nasal
strips yeah the nasal
or do i know about it no i know you know
it i need it please yeah i do it we both
you talk about nasal strips like i
talked about jared this is the second
time i've talked about nasal strip on
this [ __ ] show man i don't think so
you did a whole potluck that's when the
show's getting just right there that
even that photo oh she does look good
she does she doesn't say he looks like
the artist no no no he was just doing
one of his theo things
which we like that's a great call with
you like that's a great call yeah it's
good mark ryden i'll never forget that
yep
okay
yo would have came to sting what's
[Music]
i saw that uh episode you guys did the
other day where um no chris and theo
were talking about how great they were
so i tried them last night for the first
time
and i just didn't take it off
awesome
so uh i'm cool with walking around
outside right now looking like a
douchebag because i can breathe like
[ __ ] zeus
breathe right strips
out no
i need to see what all the fuss is about
because i have trouble breathing doing
the
cinder for guys thing if any girls out
there are digging this uh breathe right
drip
that uh clean passageway that oxygen
rich
drip
hit me up i love this guy all right
there's so many there's so many things
that you can say about this so first of
all
yes sleeping with a breathe right strip
is great okay because you don't want to
sleep with your mouth [ __ ] open for
two reasons you wake up with a sore
throat or spiders crawl in your mouth
okay or you have a mouth like a parrot
because your mouth is real dry which i
deal with every night right which sucks
so you use the breathe right dry mouth
every day so you use a breathe right
strip so you can sleep with your mouth
closed i get it in daytime when you wake
up yeah you can breathe through your
[ __ ] mouth okay you can do that so
just do that number two
if it still feels good after you wake up
you need surgery on your nose yeah you
need to get that fix but why can't he
just go out and rock that like he's
[ __ ] defensive tackle in the 90s
because of the way it looks
it doesn't look good you're supposed to
just have your face on outside that's it
right you're not supposed to also have
other things on your face i think it's
pretty lit no yeah i like seeing asians
take advantage of
technology
i like seeing uh what can happen when
people try something different me too
fan of that not the first one this guy
seems like a champion to me but also i
think it takes balls to rock that out to
wear it all day
it doesn't take balls are you just
worried about your inhaling it doesn't
take balls
the guy's got a bad nose he needs to fix
it small passageways bro i have the
worst nose in here much better like that
right how much better is that dude will
you walk behind me and just pull my
[ __ ] face like that
all day that would be amazing
fart from mile away like this what you
can also just breathe if you want no i
can't breathe i don't know which one i
had no surgery i need to get in surgery
on my head so it made it worse
what um
wow they implanted some [ __ ] in there
and there we are wow that's a call
good call she lives with a parent so is
this how about the fact that it says
meat show i know
and that's his nickname like he looked
up when you said it
meat shows a great name oh yeah
that should be on your tinder profile
welcome to the meat shop yeah or a big
new baptist ah you got that
new baptist char got named the meat show
baptist charm
charlotte
the like a baptist like
like um you know what i'm talking about
the carolers christmas carolers oh okay
oh oh oh
okay yeah sure yes but meatball add that
to your dinner profile welcome to the
meat show yeah get a baby crib this guy
couldn't look more like he's saying yeah
dude
look at him look at his skill right
there
dude
is almost empty but i am just feet away
from a gas station so let's go baby all
right oh
king king baby wow has no idea what it
is he's also i i would be willing to bet
people that roll the dice on gas are
anti-vaxxed don't wear a mask it's just
a type of never wear condoms
i've rolled in so many times on
absolutely nothing out of gas a block
and a half away just positioned it cur
perfect just enough to get up that hump
then this is the worst part some gas
stations put this big round thing in the
middle of the [ __ ] thing for no
reason i'm talking about yeah yeah you
gotta hit that [ __ ] it's like monster
jam whatever reason the [ __ ] aisle
you gotta have one last [ __ ] drip in
there
so wait uh do you and you do it yeah do
you have to do it uh do you do it in
neutral do you coast down the mountain
and hit it in neutral yeah yeah because
if you stay and drive it'll your engine
will actually stop so you've got to get
into neutral yeah so your car the end
the gas will be gone and you're just
riding whatever's left man you're right
i'll even sometimes put my hand out of
the window like this like a sailboat
just to catch up really like water you
might get a necklace like water
sometimes if i don't even need that much
wind i'll [ __ ] bring that down oh
really yeah yeah so you feel it out and
then sometimes if i'm really [ __ ]
living i'll pull them all down
just catch
enough
wow
when i was in college i had heard if you
ran out of gas and you opened up your
gas tank you could get like a couple
more miles on fumes oh that's completely
[ __ ] yeah no dude when i was like
when i was younger oh i guess
my mom had a suburban
and we used to [ __ ] yeah yeah you
rich bro we got rich man all right yeah
sound like you're got rich before you
were born no bro not before it sounds
like your dad got rich and then you then
he had no no we were poor in the
beginning yeah in the beginning no in
the beginning dude i bet your womb had
[ __ ] like at least linoleum in it
that's nice
it's nice but what happened to suburban
dude we had a suburban and one day i
realized that
my mom had like this like floodlight
kind of thing that you plugged into the
um
uh what do you call it the cigarette
lighter yeah and it would you could turn
it on it was a big light right that you
could just like
shoot out and look at everything
spotlight but bro check this out on
these suburbans that were like 1999
suburbans you could [ __ ] do this
weird thing
what is it that
you could hold the alarm button and it
would go off while you were driving so
you could hold it and you'd be driving
and it would take the light out and i
would pull people over
i'd pull him over and bro
we would [ __ ] [ __ ] ourselves we'd
pull people over they'd pull over and
then we'd show up and we were just like
these [ __ ] 19 year olds in [ __ ]
that just got out of high school and we
would be laughing at them bro it was so
fun and that's the end of the story
isn't that [ __ ] amazing
no it is in the store and i'll tell you
something my friend billy one time we
got stopped by the cop for doing
something right he said you guys are
coming to jail with me so i'm sitting in
the passenger seat the cops like follow
me to jail right because we're in
billy's car
so we pull up we're like uh a couple
blocks from the jail we stop at a stop
light and billy's like [ __ ] man we're
going to jail and i was like i'm not and
i just got out of the car
i would have pulled you over i would
have pulled you over right behind you
i got him
then i'm in this family suburban we're
just going to olive garden or pizza
until you run out of gas and then your
hand comes out and i'm like well he's
not he got that much longer his middle
finger's up we got him
bro i after a big fight i knocked some
dude out i had a hummer wow our stories
are all much different
i had a hummer h2 i just got it and it
was on like big ass monster truck tires
of course you did it
yeah it's so crazy yeah it was middle of
the snow and the
on the hummers the gas tank was low i'm
like i can ride this bike
it's a guzzler hummers don't no you
can't there's no this no there's none of
that can't do that runs out of gas i had
to push it into the gas station now
we're going to pay the guy goes d what
you just on tv wow did i just [ __ ]
see him like jagers they gotta pay you
more man yeah you're [ __ ] telling me
dude you need one more pay me more oh
wow and that because you should have
questions
that's six dollars for gas finish it up
chris and you got it
and that's the end of the story you need
to cap it like that dude um amazing that
guy's me that's in the wild
this is the plane for the sixers so a
lot of people have been telling me this
this is who's this guy who is that uh
his last name
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh that's exactly who you would be yeah
a lot of people say that but before him
it was pogba which is you do look like
paul in the face
you guys all look like birds yeah
there's always a [ __ ] basketball
there's always a basketball player that
looks like me yeah that's true yeah it's
just how it's going to be from now
european yeah the croats too
chin what's up with you dude i haven't
heard from you in a couple of years
what's up with me huh yeah dude yeah
what's going on man what's up dude not
much man just working here nice studio
enjoying life taking notes
right who's lying
nothing much just working here hello
alvin taking notes hello good time yeah
enjoy it let me know when you spit i'll
be there to catch it
there's another cats in the wild
evidently brendan passed in the ukraine
russia border crisis wow
oh [ __ ] oh damn wow oh [ __ ] wow and
theo's in the casket you know
that's what we got
wow wow that's pretty good wow
not bad wow who who was watching this
like it looks like shopping
i don't actually see it i don't see it
really yeah when you first see it yeah
it looked like yeah i see it i see it so
many guys that i meet at shows
that look just like brendan
wow really even though it just happened
now
so many okay wow well you got like those
[ __ ] minority report fans that see
the [ __ ] in the future
that's amazing i could i don't know yeah
well they do
yeah
in the future
oh man
okay so what about this one
what's up
right now
right now that was the most insecure
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my mind
that first second was holy [ __ ] cut
that part
dude that guy's got a dick that is
bigger when it's soft yeah
when it gets hard it shrinks dude that's
unbelievable let's see if i think the
guy was just maybe something happened in
the room someone came into the room
let's see one more i think he's nervous
here he's nervous sure pause her earlier
cut it out no just let her play oh yeah
you play again it's just one second
yeah well let's see what he says
what's up brendan big
theo definitely nick and chen
uh maybe chris maybe stevie definitely
eric i love you eric
hey guys um watch out for the fan covers
i pay a little bit extra for review
now oh okay
i don't know if you can see that but a
pond non-winter that's actually a really
beautiful view of the water during
winter it's just [ __ ] ice oh anyways
that's my king and they're stinging do
the video
i want to say
if you are somewhere and you have the
opportunity to spend the money to get
you something good and you have the
money and you have it or you even barely
have it sure spend the money i was in
africa one time
really i had a chance to buy a human
skull right human skull okay
it was 600 i'm in
i don't spend the money end up getting
like
so we ended up at a different store
didn't have the same opportunities there
and ended up getting like a candle like
this really cool candle right
but every time
i
like that candle all i think of is just
how cheap i was and how cool it would
have been to have the skull now do we
think that having a human skull in the
house would be a good thing though in
hindsight oh hold on a second
hold on wait a second where i'm from
people have all kind of they have all
kind of people bury their family in the
in the yard we have you know yeah but
they don't keep their skulls on their
feet
close though
hold on no 20 feet away that is nothing
like what this [ __ ] guy is asking
you're talking about buying a human
head
this guy's talking about buying
something that every morning wake up and
look out and feel good and you're
talking about buying someone no i'm
waiting
on this but it's he regrets it no dude
don't buy
people it's the cost effect ratio chin
how much was the candle huh how much was
the candle thirty bucks okay so you
saved
570
and you didn't buy someone's head yeah
think about that probably every
[ __ ] day
walk up and go like this yeah so that is
the real thing you have just not the
same you have problems yeah but to own a
little piece of you you're jeffrey
dahmer
you're jeffrey dahmer so you die you die
all right and then someone picks you up
saws your [ __ ] head off
dries you out picks up your [ __ ]
mullet and your [ __ ] skin out and
then says hey to some jerky american do
you want to buy this guy's head for 600
and that's you [ __ ] and then you
wind up in somebody's [ __ ] loft or
one bedroom apartment or can you sleep
or on king of the sting yeah yeah
so you wind up with some shitty podcasts
i like it
you're bullshitting man i'd like it man
you get to go you get to be so where
else you going to end up huh i'm with
you on this man sounds pretty where else
you want andy tell me where else you're
gonna end up huh you know what i wanna
use it when i die
[ __ ] throw me as far as you can to
the show wherever i land no wherever i
die pick me up and just toss me out 30
feet i'll wind up sideways near a gate
somewhere leave me there don't ever bury
me don't burn me up i want people to
walk by for months and be like is that
that comedian
and that's it and then i disintegrate
and die the way it should be you know
what i want i want uh to do like a remix
on shark week you know how they put
those fake seals behind the boat and the
great white [ __ ] jumps out put my
dead body on a rope and just have one of
those [ __ ] great whites come out of
the water wow and then you guys are
there crying you're on the boat and
stuff deals
cheering out there
we could zoom yeah yeah i'll assume it
was going to zoom in from nashville
here's what i was gonna even miss that
when i'm dead first of all
get me in one of those cannons one of
those party cannons or whatever
shoot me into a [ __ ] school yard at
recess oh like evil knievel with
children out there right whatever kid
comes up right and either hits me with a
stick or calls me a [ __ ]
gets all the money i have when i die
whoa wow and that'll be a lot of money
probably that's a good reality
that's a dope show but that wouldn't
that be great dude all the kids are
gonna run but it's gonna be the one
creepy [ __ ] kid yeah who's gonna walk
up that's dude that's the steal when he
dies with his arms down i'm gonna be
like you get three hundred dollars in a
human skull yeah you know and i'm just
dead just like this yeah
you but your body hits the ground and
then it scrapes forward a little bit
like that and it's just so much your ass
up you put your ass up yeah the ass up
and some kid comes and looks in my ass
that kid gets all the money wow no the
money's in your ass yeah and then he
grabs it out yeah and he goes i got it
yeah
it's like easter
let's how many skulls can we buy
[Laughter]
shaver chest good morning king in the
this is xavier what's up guys i got a i
got a hollow thingy for y'all bringing
your personal vehicle
right here that's my motorcycle
out to the racetrack
yes i'm about uh
you know i'm out at south supermoto in
riverside and i'm about to ride my
motorcycle on the track have some fun
push it to the limits what do you guys
think brendan take that ferrari to the
racetrack man take it to willow springs
have some fun with it
imagine if you did that's the thing
about this stuff i have that gt2 which
is a race car i'm not trying to [ __ ] up
the tires right right burn all that [ __ ]
out i'd rather you somebody else's you
feel me
yeah but if he's got the [ __ ] dirt
bike you might as well take the dirt
bike
but then go on dirt dude is that what
that is get a crotch rock and [ __ ]
take it on the track that thing's
supposed to be on like [ __ ] dirt you
gotta use stuff burning if you have
stuff you have to use it i do it on the
405 the 101 daddy but that ain't using
it it is though oh my gosh they're
risking this i live my life one quarter
mile at a time
but still man you know what i don't even
live my life it's someone else
you know someone else is doing it hello
the alvin
spit in my mouth
you want your kids to know that you're
just doing you're just bumper to bumper
dad i'm not bumping a bumper i'm [ __ ]
zigzagging through traffic i'm the guy
in the carpool when i don't have an
extra person
you almost died in that car fire
remember yeah i did
oh yeah
but instead you live
yeah
dark stuff dude you gotta i think that's
the thing how do you die for your kids
you know well actually that's not the
thing though because the thing was
should you take your bike out
well fine if you guys want to take the
easy
that's your call i want my when i grow
up i want see here's the thing if my kid
i want my kid to usurp me and be better
than me and have to you know kill me for
some really grand reason and for him to
kill me and while he's doing it i look
at him and i and i cry one tear and i
say i'm proud of you son and that's how
i go oh
beautiful that's cool dude i didn't see
that
and i knew you were gonna say that and
that's weird because i didn't see it but
you knew but i knew yeah so what's going
on in the universe
i don't know really i think a lot of
it's what are people talking about the
weather climate change or whatever
mostly i think a lot of people are
talking about our
patreon
if uh you want to join our patreon you
gotta pay yeah two
episodes a month right dos patreons
day
month oh monto
three amigos here on patreon twice a
month every other week man exclusive
exclusive coming in
exclusive no ads no talking about draft
kings
no nothing we don't even call it we're
just sitting there
yeah we'll be faking this first one next
week that's right first one next
week get on that [ __ ] sign up on the
patreon
now right now patreon king the sting
and the wing that's it kids yeah i'll be
a natural they'll theo be in your
backyard man hopefully i see you buddy
nice what dates what is it 10 11 and 12.
yeah i'm in nashville the 10th 11th the
12th all right zaney's in nashville and
then i am in chicago end of this month
end of march i'm in chicago tickets are
stand up live and phoenix just went on
sale get you some get that patreon it's
the king the sting and the wing twice a
month on patreon only with the three
amigos here hammond just i will be in
irvine uh california go to chrisley.com
for tickets crystalia and friends
and i will be i have a show coming up in
uh los angeles on may 7. um and some
more shows will be added um looking
forward to that and um the will turn i'm
excited for this patreon man yeah we're
taking the our
our [ __ ] in our own hands yeah that's
why we're doing it man yeah and they're
re-releasing my netflix special too what
do you mean the audio
on which one on the uh last one they're
re-releasing whose fault is that what
are we doing why why is the audio back
it was crazy bro but they released it
yeah they realized the audio was [ __ ]
up pulled it now they're re-releasing
they didn't pull it there but there we
just twice the phone did it twice the
fun yeah i didn't know i didn't said it
never happened before
they said just like the mix was not good
and that's on them because they produced
it right
yeah we had producers but i mean they
had they had like people involved yeah
they have uh
weird very strange yeah just dub it over
in like spanish that would be maybe that
would make up for they're doing that
that'd be cool actually yeah the whole
thing was in a uh
falcons died dude we need to get a human
i just got an alert when a falcon
we need to get a human skull for this
for the studio hey bro he [ __ ] up
right well i wanted to get that nose
well now i don't know what to do for his
birthday right just give him yours bro
you can get it on the dark web i'm sure
ari mantis could find one well i'm sure
nick knows where you know
in two weeks it's the birthday episode
for you three oh yeah oh 18 oh yeah
that's right you're 19. and i'm 29th
well we're pisces bros and you're and
i'm keeping it real dude
aries aries dude sore
fire does aries soar what is aries a
bird it's a ram i think
that's weird not sure honestly i don't
know anything about that [ __ ] iran could
be a monkey for all i know
you don't know your sign what it is i
don't what is it nick i know it brown
rim oh okay and what's the favorite sign
right now chen the best sign the most
popular sign the scorpion yields scorpio
popping yell just joke like this is a
sign oh well the taurus
you're the lion
all right kids love you well subscribe
to patreon yep see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
theo said that he was on his way but ran
out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at
[Music]
is king in the state what up chin what
up nick stevie weeby eric griffin just
walked in and got it lit you can't
forget about brendan he still need
everything dick dick still got the bees
and the trap trapping still the king in
the sting so quit asking if you know
then you know it's a cat's thing ball
and chain hair swang like the rat cam
king and the stink
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan do2 yeah you know
how we do it so just tune in for the
laughs theo said that he was on his way
but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting